oh wow it was a hot start to the weekend
for sure at 108 and then temps started
sliding
down to 103 yesterday so that was nice
a little bit of a relief but boy we
traded some heat for a lot of gusty
winds
and those winds are kicking up some dust
out there we're going to keep some of
that dust around
also elevated ozone as well so we've had
a lot of ozone because of the heat and
the sunlight
we're going to keep some ozone but the
dust you'll notice today with those
winds
moderate olive ragweed and grass is also
blooming
so temperatures around the valley we
found some 70s out there so that's good
some 80s still in the interior of the
valley but we are cooling off
we're even going to get mornings in the
60s in the valley here midweek
oh that's going to feel good mid 70s for
indian springs and prom caliente in the
60s
near 80 for mesquite and boulder city
right now low 80s laughlin
57 up there in ely so here's a couple of
things it's a cooler trough that's
overall going to make the noticeable
difference in temperatures this week
but those southerly that southerly
influence is pulling up some high clouds
off the coast of southern california so
we'll continue to see those clouds
moving in
all day mixing up with our sunshine
because the winds are still very very
dry
we're keeping the red flag warnings
national weather service has actually
extended those now
all the way until wednesday night i
talked about the lake wind advisory
that's been reissued for lake mead
and all the way down the colorado river
valley today that's from noon until 8 pm
just like it was yesterday
97 for the high a mix of sunshine and
clouds and those gusty winds that will
continue
and then we're looking at fewer clouds
tomorrow but still breezy to windy for
tuesday
and look how the temperatures drop in
from upper 90s to mid 90s even down to
90 degrees on thursday
should be the coolest day and there's a
couple of mornings in the 60s
and then we ramp right back up to triple
digits for the weekend
104-105 yikes